you
here we go here we go double those
points where's that where's the ticker I
get over here ticker
get over here ticker I was tempted to go
for that strike on f7 that was almost a
bad Castle Knight takes pawn
let's get that what is this what do we
even call this top that a bad gambit we
call that a bad gambit he was free he
was the freest pun around okay so now
I'm going to go after f7 I haven't given
up on f7 but not so fast actually don't
want to drop that Queen and now we're
gonna do something dangerous I'm hitting
the knight and f7 that's a problem let's
get rid of him and I'm gonna hit this
pawn a third time there's some serious
issues on f7 and h7 could be mate very
soon actually we could see cool mate
Queen takes pawn queen here Knight f7b
mate you might see a cool mate
tough to defend h7 and f7 if the knight
moves there's Queen takes King in the
corner Queen's g8 Knight f7 me
it's my probably gonna move baby it
spawns hit three times defended once it
can't be defended twice with blacks next
move 16 seconds they're gonna let the
time tick away they reside back
determine I guess there wasn't a good
defense there was a well I'm pretty sure
there wasn't any defense I thought we
might see though some smothered me all
right
my opponent I'm sure Oh the Smith Maura
no thank you that's what I say that my
opponent is well aware of the fishing
pole and I'm going to oh they couldn't
castle anyhow let's do that
let's do that wonderful wonderful
descriptions what are you going to do
yeah I'm gonna do that I'm gonna run
away on purpose Bishop here okay I have
to give up my my dark square Bishop I'm
just going to castle take like this I
guess I want to kick him away I want to
open up the position my pony isn't
Castle I got to watch out for stuff
though yeah I have to be careful
I have serious darker weaknesses serious
starts car weaknesses oh okay I'm not
gonna take that pawn that bishops too
scary they're gonna win a pawn though
they're gonna win a pawn queen trade
Queen trade come on Exchange get rid of
their dark square Bishop get rid of him
he's a bad man pawn push and Bishop here
okay you could still take him hang on
they were being sneaky although I did
have Queen check and then a recapture on
h6 this game feels like it's going in
slow motion where is their quick win
there's no quick wins around no quick
grant wins here rook takes a less than
ten grab apollon might be time burner
mode I think it is it's time to just
throw in checks and chew up time oh oh
there was lag there I gotta watch out
for the lag that was not a good idea
after all
Queen trade still
okay anything anything finally that
clock was not ticking 20 2012 12 10 and
then there's a six way down below I
already feel like I need to go for f7
strikes
okay this night's pushed around with
tempo let's push him around still okay
still pushing still pushing let's push
him around
oh what a bully what a bully I'm being
right now you think you could just push
your opponent around like that shame on
you I have h4 covered a very important
detail let's get rid of him
I'm on this I'm on the rook he can't be
defended imagine that I'm gonna save my
knight I'm getting pushed around now
Oh Knight here this is this is where I
want to be I'm gonna get mate right here
that's where he belongs
I don't have to take the rook I'm gonna
give a check recapturing than made on e7
I know I'm not gonna take with the pawn
on and take with the Queen otherwise
there's queenside castle now that's me
now it's fairly quick somebody has 30
though 30 2017 then twelves e 6d v
France did I read that right let's throw
the nihms oh oh oh go at my point
actually these variations don't work I
have to I have to go for some other
stuff can I actually still get this out
of the nihms oh god head take them my
pony is well aware of mine my tricky
stuff well aware of the tricky stuff
taking me the B file wanna get rid of
their LightSquared Bishop I want to be
on the light squares Oh
all right let's train a little bit I
guess this game is not gonna end any
time soon
okay end game I want to play against
this pawn keep this structure I don't
want to take here because then I have to
worry about f7 stand this only open file
this game is not gonna end that's a free
pun let's take here first and that's
another free pawn let's give a check
first probably shouldn't have done that
get these guys in position where are you
at you belong over here oh let's take
that guy don't let this pawn run pond
you're fast in your past I think oh I
didn't mean to do that hmm
can I still win this I think I could run
King run run run run run run run run run
is the plan oh I still have this 9
seconds sneak over don't drop your rook
whatever you do oh come on inch by inch
we're getting there you could do it this
is this is a dumb way right over here
we're dancing I don't want to dance
finally 1.80 no oh if you went in the
other direction I would have got him I
would not have got him put me but in the
corner that's exactly what I need to see
he needs to go in the corner oh that one
was grueling oh it took forever oh my
goodness where are the quick wins let's
block that let's block that I don't like
this pawn push bishop pen and stuff okay
okay I'm gonna take this bishop as an
in-betweener if that happens that's not
happening
he's dropping back now look at this ugly
ugly structure who was asking earlier
about bad bishops he was a bad bishop my
opponent just took him he was a bad
bishop but I just make up my mind with
my light-square bishop let's go over
here I'm gonna secure this point with my
knight if he puts pressure on him and
take him out I'm looking for a good
night versus bad bishop situation can I
get that not really
all right we're gonna I have to get this
advance in yeah hang on
oh I get this pun let's take this at the
end of it I think I get this pun Wow
I've got a pun I've got a pun and I have
to try and win a bishop end game up a
pond I could get this die thinking okay
let's establish a pond on dark square
first we had a bishop trade go back here
and then we have Bishop trade by force
hmm oh no their King is fast no my Kings
faster I thought he could sneak down
here okay past pond
let's stop theirs from moving keep
moving mine they were being sneaky
they're being sneaky again okay go
faster when we have these hang on was
that gonna be stalemate just make sure
it's not stalemate keep sniffing check
5440 3937 I'm not satisfied with any of
these games none of them none of them
I'm one sad I'm just not satisfied until
I could get made on each - that's just
how it is I need to get my my fill of h2
we could be seeing it we could be seeing
it H - H - watch out 70 42 40 39 39 37
Elvis Chesley Ellis Chesley they
resigned back to tournament just like
that I got a boost 70 53
let's try it again another one okay
tempo on the Queen oh she's gone just
like that the Queen the Queen has left
the building
the Queen has left the building
somebody was being clever just there
somebody was being clever who was it it
was being clever oh my goodness could I
just move I'm up a queen
does it really matter get your pieces
out get your pieces out I actually have
thoughts of H - H - H - H - there it is
70 65 54 the goal is to mate on H to
every game maybe I could do it on the
white side maybe I could do it on the
white side alright
complain like um reverse Sicilians I
usually just do it from the black side
what's wrong with this side I take him
you take him he's probably free he
really is he probably is free I promise
it's already dangerous for my opponent
it's already dangerous [ __ ] there and I
have nothing there on my Rick I'm on
there's that are out of the line of fire
though we're getting out the Queen trade
aren't we I guess so look at him he's
having a tough day at the office on D -
okay my King needs to find a new home
and his new home is on e3 I want to pile
up on him who was saying an earlier bad
bishop protect good pawns I think that's
the situation I was just in let's defend
my second rank my King's gonna get
kicked
let's double
let's go here and then here and then
here
excellent descriptive miss
descriptiveness let's get these pawns
marching where is my time where is my
time yeah this is going to be a game
that's very difficult to win
where are the time burners where the
time burners okay I get this okay you
give a check
No
oh yeah that's what I was afraid of nine
seconds make sure I get that pun give a
check yes I don't know oh no no no no
why can't I go fast my King needs to
move help out King do something do
something even if it's wrong do
something even if it's wrong get out of
the way make up my mind go to the corner
back to the tournament eighty eight
eighty three seventy my heart isn't
might throw it with that last game my
heart is in my throat my heart is in my
throat with that last game this is the
one-minute madness if you're just tuning
in okay let's put pressure on that guy
actually might be five that's gonna hurt
that would have hurt okay I think they
meant Queenie to to exchange dark square
bishop I have a pawn presence in the
center let's get him rolling bishop
check I block I'm gonna go clean side
sneaky bishop here okay they fell for a
knight here that was a bad move that was
um not a good thing to do in regular
chess game where you make a less than
optimal move and then cross your fingers
and hope that's that's called bad chess
play don't do that ever ever in longer
games bullet it's okay okay where were
we at they resigned in from that
position the Queen was pinned and now
the queen is gone take with the King on
castled
this is not so easy to exploit I help my
development out I don't want to help
theirs out let's pin this knight
queenside castle in there discovered
tricks discovered tricks discovered
tricks where are they
okay digit I should take it with the
bishop I would have been up a piece okay
I'm still up um I'll be up something
from this variation as well I don't have
to take with the knight he's hit twice
defended nun now I got that rook
there's no bishop check there's no
bishop check more material I should be
nothing very soon very soon grab these
guys pac-man mode and run the a pond
watch out for stalemates cut the King
off they resigned back to terminal 123
108 98 85 85 less than 14 minutes remain
less than 14 minutes okay let's try some
dragon some dragon maybe e6 and D 5 D 6
and D 5 take I get this square Knight F
knight on f5 is awesome the knight on f5
is awesome or maybe Bishop here first
and winning upon they don't have enough
defense for a knight here he's going
astray let's trade rook on c8 and EA the
open files I don't know 5 is very good
here next tricky stuff on this diagonal
and maybe get at this point but all my
piece is working I could have just done
that this comes with check and then
we're gonna have a fork yeah could take
that bishop and have a new queen on the
scene end up getting a rook at the end
of that probably miss some type of mates
on f2 or Knight g3 stuff when I had
control over that diagonal and the rook
take this pawn next night off to stuff
or not here
no prevent that traffic come on anything
this beam is not gonna finish I don't
think they resigned back to tournament
143 128 105 105 to keep winning I have
to keep winning because there are other
guys who could sneak right up on you
okay that I'm tempted 495 stuff a six
I'll play a four maybe there's no need
to do this 95 stuff no I guess I'm gonna
take him pawn push I have to take first
cuz he's hit twice d5 is a good idea
actually I'm gonna go with this maybe
have this tactic Knight takes pawn
Knight takes here to be careful I'm
gonna take this I want to break this
stuff down Queen takes Knight here I'm
defending this twice it was just
attacked twice development on f4 with
the tempo okay and I think follow up
here of a fork is a good idea Queen here
might be some pawn push with check rook
here doesn't work now
and now oh that's me back to tournament
163 126 118 11 minutes remaining 11
minutes remaining TS TS ba
alright I have my little fort now built
up that is highly highly committal that
G formal one of the most committal moves
oh my how how do I take advantage of
that why dad why did I just do that move
that was dangerous that was dangerous
get this Knight out of here and then oh
he didn't run away I wasn't expecting
that I wanted to follow up like this
yeah I don't I don't want the night to
be able to make use of that where is my
room to maneuver let's do this my knight
wants to be here I have an idea now
night on c4 this bishop isn't doing
anything take like this open the
diagonal for my bishop I want it he's a
bad guy
he's my bad [ __ ] hub so so what so
let's get rid of them oh I'm so fearful
of night here I have to retreat I'm
fearful of that pond from pushing should
just plate here okay let's get rid of
the dark square bishop yeah that's
sneaky that's sneaky oh the Knights dead
my knight is dead my knight is
officially dead okay let me just get
castled his pawns gonna push no I get
the rook with the Queen here unless
there's that move nine seconds I just
get loud right there
and I just get loud right there I need
to fly oh they dropped their queen it's
exactly what I needed that is exactly
what I needed anything moves anything
moves for seconds I should probably take
in one of the rooks at one point time
burners is what I need though back to
terment they're down on time 183 146 138
134 is my time I have very little time
very little time actually the more that
there's a rating difference the less
time you have that's where your time is
going that's where your time is going
that's really cool to clean and now the
rook are gone the Queen and rook are
gone we might have a quick resigner No
okay let me finish my development I
don't care about my knight
I don't care about him g3 Bishop g2
watch out for me bishop here imagine
that imagine the scream imagine the
scream just imagine it had been loud
never never with headphones would you
listen you know I'm going to attack the
King at some point hopefully soon the
night is now hit he's not defended
throwing that check if there's the rook
in a block what do you really do that
anything anything where's the mate
there's got to be a quicker main Bishop
here no that's not me
we're getting there he's gotta go
why can't I find a mate this kid can I
just take this night and have the game
end no steal mates it's he's hiding
he is definitely hiding it's a Megan to
unavoidable no it's a Megan one I lied
on that one
I was thinking rook I looked down and
over rookie five to age five I think I
have the squares correct b-52h five and
then I realized there was a mate in one
okay can i maybe I could get in each two
in let's establish the center Knights
head let's just no I should have taken
here first
okay now their king he doesn't have a
good home he's trying to run away but
I'm gonna pile up on this and come back
over age - I have not given up on I have
not given up on each - I insist I insist
each - just like that - 23 178 okay I
need to try and get it on the white side
I haven't done that just yet actually g3
is unnecessary if I'm gonna be going for
this h2 stuff what is this this is
actually uh oh I'm winning a piece now I
was gonna say this is actually an
opening didn't make it make a whole lot
of sense
oh is that what it is it's an opening
and I think that was at least the white
setup I have them covered enough oh but
if Queen takes now I could block with my
bishop and then complete development
let's do it right now what am i what am
I waiting for
okay I might end up losing the exchange
or something yeah but I'm okay with that
take with my bishop my bishop back on
this light square diagonal soon queens
are off
the bishop pair versus rook tricky stuff
skewers they avoided that thrown at my
pond it's fast they resigned back to
term at 200 we're on our way to 243 178
175 167 it's been a while since I did
the one-minute madness five minutes
remaining in this tournament five
minutes remain
let's try the Benko gambit the Benko
gambit all right no it's not a gambit
I still have play on the B file and I
didn't have to invest any material any
pawns in order to get just that but my
opponent is coming at me strong here and
this e5 push is soon to be happening so
I want to eliminate the knight who's
watching over a five and I want to watch
over c4 I want to go other night here
and I want to think about pushing maybe
jumping into here one day d3 i queen
doing something I have to be careful
about a knight getting here mmm let's
just try to jump in jump in I know
that's just not working
the Queen is guarding that duck along a
diagonal so that was not a good idea but
I'm gonna go with this and hopefully
they're still going to be some pressure
that I could have against the Queen side
pawns should I have really given that up
now this pawn has passed
let's see what happens here a night here
I could take this pawn not anymore
pawn takes I take with my king on this
guy twice I don't know how to make
progress there it is I did that I think
in a five minute game when in doubt move
your age pond I can't come up with the
plan here so that's why I was building
with that what am i doing what am i
doing
take that now I guess my king will be
over here to stop this pond from getting
past I should have played up I've got to
get rid of some of their ponds and get
rid of this guy okay he's gone let's
come over here and get him not so fast
my opponent says not so fast I should
have given a check first let's cut that
King off and then March my own pawns I
don't have a lot of time
okay do that and then this and then
create a outside past on any type of
move and I'll have any time wow that was
a fight and a half to 63 205 204 two
minutes remain
226 okay okay that's what the tempo this
is with tempo as well I'm dropping this
pun now I'm defending it
grab some space with the tempo same
story here and secure this point
actually or nothing stopping me from
that Greek gift sacrifice right and then
jump out with the clean tape right here
otherwise it's a matin on each seven now
rook here one two three four five is me
think something very close to it no make
it to me make it to the end ahead of
myself there I had control over g7 283
mystic I started off playing against I
started off the tournament against this
guy
okay f3 gambit style and it's gonna get
pushed around I guess we are entering
that Ivan I've wasted so much time with
I was thinking about getting my darks
for a bishop outside of the pawn chain
but I just want to do east six and get
King side Castle otherwise I think d5
would have been there soon I'd love to
have light square bishop scum off we
have just that so now I could better
rely upon this home on d5 right takes
take with my queen that's a strong post
get in this half open guard completely
open file I'm on a two as well I need a
flight square alright let's take care
be able to defend let's drop back the
bishop can't move and give check just in
case g7 is an issue let's do that he's
uh I was defending okay I almost dropped
my Kleenex I was gonna play Bishop here
and pin the rook they resigned back to
Turman 18 seconds remain I don't know if
this is even gonna start up Gerry's
squared
Jerry squared is this a sneaky player is
this a sneaky player having flashbacks
of sneakiness no they're calling the
tournament they're calling the
tournament it just came up those little
cubits all right
first place confetti let's close out
okay good games all alright 303 to 45 to
35 I had a lot of games in there and a
couple couple quick ones there
you
[Music]